Time Thief Time Thief fire him dght
you've really never stolen any company
time never you are a thief of Joy
anybody else hey you know what Dwight
maybe we should get our photo ID taken
together that doesn't make any sense
well it saves time you know cuz we could
just meet in the parking lot every
morning walking together Perfect Smile
no I never smile if I can help it
showing one's teeth is a submission
signal in primates once someone Smiles
at me all I see is a chimpanzee begging
for its
life are you kidding well I'm not done
yet Dwight this fits in the palm of my
hand you haven't blown them up enough
why have you chosen Brown and gray
balloons they match the carpet what is
that it is your birthday period
statement a fact not even an exclamation
point this is more professional it's not
like she discovered a cure for cancer my
perfect Val Valentine's Day I'm at home
three cell phones in front of me
Fielding desperate calls from people who
want to buy one of the 50 restaurant
reservations I made over six months ago
Dwight has been acting manager for 3
months now NOP a week just feels like
three months Let's see we all have to
punch into a Time Clock which is very
old very strong and has the slot about
the size of a finger we were all given
new business cards big enough to set us
apart from the competition which is how
I learned that our titles are all now
Junior employee our lunch breaks are
staggered to prevent wasting time mine's
at 10:30 and I find that the first hour
of the day goes by a lot quicker than
the second seven hours what should we do
with all these leftovers I'm taking the
dumplings for my wife no no no this is
your last meal there will be no
leftovers I can bring these to my
shelter I'm taking my
dumplings oh there take those home to
your
wife
no one should be planking at all thank
you
yes Dwight my enforcer my number two can
you take care of this say no
more kids don't try blanking it's
dangerous especially with me
around uh on or off off okay oh what is
on your face is that a
disguise excuse
me clown
paint insert it in my mouth okay that's
not going to make your pizza eating
experience any better trust me oh try me
Jim just don't think of it as degrading
think of it as you happen to be moving
the pizza 6 in this way and he happens
to be biting it I prefer for him to
think of it as degrading
okay crust
first
okay now the
beer beer me
Jam
gentle now I've got to go meet Angela is
there a birthday that you remember that
you loved here's one
it was dark warm
wet a sudden burst of light an intense
pressure like i' had never felt before
father dressed in white pulls me forward
mother bites the cord okay stop forever
stop that story that's disgusting and it
doesn't count so give me another one shs
don't celebrate birthdays idiot it
started as a Depression era practicality
and then moved on to an awesome
tradition that I look forward to every
year what about you actually when I was
seven my dad took me Natural History
Museum New York and we looked at fossils
all day and at the end of the day he got
me a little plastic Triceratops it was
awesome that's cool hey you know what's
even cooler than
Triceratops every other dinosaur that
ever
existed didn't see that one coming we
will be leaving the office for one whole
week nice job in my contract it is
stipulated that I provide a temporary
workspace it will arrive in 1 hour what
what's this oh what bring it in roll
into the future with work bus say
goodbye to wasteful buildings these days
a mobile office isn't just for Hot Shot
politicians now anyone can rent a work
bus if you've got a parking lot a
workspace is just a phone call away in
this age of belt tight this is smaller
than your old place yes while I'm buying
it and I'm not renting it so it's still
an
upgrade this my friends is the master
bedroom check out the cathedral ceilings
those are like 17 ft High we have cable
Readiness right there I am going to
totally pimp this place out I'm going to
put a surround sound system I'm going to
put a plasma screen right against this
wall putting my bed right over here no
no no no no no this is a shared wall
neighbor throws his wife into the wall
plasma screen hits the floor totally
smashed well then I will get a warranty
warrant don't cover plus her a rip off
well then I won't get a warranty so
that's the problem is solved
what can you hear
that oh
man these babies are
thin what kind of mortgage did you get
uh 10 year Well 10 over 30 so 30 year
total what what you said
10 10 year
fixed over 30 30 year total oh 30 years
okay okay wow you'll be paying the off
in your mid 70s all right forget about
retiring when you're 65 hey I got an
idea you know that extra bedroom if the
whole girlfriend thing never happens
that's where the nurse can live okay all
right Sydney go Sydney
Sydney hold it neck back insert the
knife beneath the jaw bring it all the
way around there's going to be a good
amount of blood don't let that bother
you have a bucket there for the blood
and the inard and the feathers I'm so
sorry for all of this it's okay you know
what they say A change is as good as a
rest I I need to get to the paper
please oh my God I'll get your napkins
someone get napkins please you know what
it's fine it's fine let me just it's
fine damn I'm really sorry
I I'm I'm really sorry about all
that really
smirking what can I say I love Justice
you you forced me to spend money on
needless repairs and uh now you're
locked in a prison bus and your woman
drips with beverage hey Dwight I was
trying to do something nice for Pam can
you just help me out can we maybe take
this thing somewhere or do something to
not make this the worst day ever it's
not my responsibility to solve your
marriage problems by spending my money
on
gas birthday time is over now go make up
for all the work you missed when you
were taking your nap Pixar Michael Yes
drop this one abor why I found
twins oh my God twins I'm sorry you
understand nice to meet
you aren't they
magnificent they're men
Dwight I love finding a good set of
twins something is wrong with you